[Música]
llegamos a la revista de prensa ya está
lista en el estudio rosa pérez masdéu
rosa bienvenida hoy va a estar muy
chévere esta sección de revista de
prensa ya al final pero vamos a abrir
entonces con la sección del tema de la
jornada al día de la lucha contra la
violencia machista para ello tenemos una
sección de tres artículos de diez y
distintos puntos de vista rosa exacto
raúl hemos querido seleccionar pues
distintos temas no relacionados con la
jornada de hoy si te parece empezamos
por el periódico de españa así es rosa
empezamos por el periódico que dice
porque el 25 ene es el día en contra de
la violencia machista este artículo se
remonta a lo sucedido el 25 de noviembre
de 1960 en república dominicana cuando
la policía del régimen de rafael
trujillo
asesinó a las hermanas mirabal en las
hermanas patria minerva y maría teresa
activistas políticas contra el régimen
de hecho las interceptó las hago las
golpeó y las islas tiro por un barranco
y él quiso simular que se trató de un
accidente que evidentemente conmocionó a
la sociedad raíz de ahí naciones unidas
empezó a trabajar en declaraciones
contra la discriminación contra las
mujeres y más tarde en
1999 se declaró este 25 de noviembre
como día internacional de lucha contra
la violencia de las mujeres condenamos
contra la cronología ahora de pícara
magazine de violencia doméstica
violencia es machista la importancia de
los conceptos rosa exacto este artículo
de esta revista feminista de españa' lo
que señala es la importancia de llamar a
las cosas por su nombre podríamos
decirlo así y diferenciar entre los
casos del ámbito privado no es señala
que llamar violencia doméstica la
violencia machista pues al final lo
conceptualiza como casos individuales
que tienen que ver con la esfera es o
privada y señala la importancia de
considerar estas violencias como una
cuestión estructural de la sociedad como
un problema político y social porque
recordemos raúl que si bien estas
violencias tienen expresiones distintas
contra mujeres trans de clase alta de
clase baja racial izadas de orígenes
nacionalidades
pues eso culturas distintas hay un
denominador común y es que estas
violencias se ejercen contra las mujeres
por el hecho de estar asociadas al rol
de género femenino en sociedades
patriarcales rosa cerramos esta sección
entonces de este 25 ene con una
herramienta dispuesta por el medio
feminista perdón manifiesta punto o
hereje de colombia directorio para
mujeres y niñas de violencias basadas en
género exacto hemos querido puedes
hablar de esta herramienta que ha puesto
a disposición la revista manifiesta y lo
que hace es unir todas las líneas de
atención y los centros de atención para
víctimas de la violencia machista en los
32 departamentos de colombia es una
herramienta pues que la queríamos dar a
conocer y continuamos rosa con los
acontecimientos históricos pero
centrados en este año mil 21 veamos las
100 imágenes seleccionadas por la
revista 'time' a esta sección a este
momento de esta sección ya yo quería
llegar los síes que son a tantas cosas
raúl yo no sé si he venido arriba un
poco con esta selección porque yo no
sabía que dejar de lado y realmente hay
hechos que incluso se nos podían haber
olvidado de tantas cosas que han
sucedido en este 2021 no le damos un
vistazo los televidentes y ya que ellos
se entregan a la revista 'time' vida en
estas fotos que son unas fotos as exacto
mira esto empezamos con esta imagen de
los incendios de grecia no cada vez más
devastadores en el verano del hemisferio
norte pues consecuencia en gran parte
del cambio climático no pues el puro
rostro de la desesperación raúl la
siguiente imagen a ver si la vemos ahora
es de finales de mayo del 24 de mayo en
la franja de gaza tras el alto al fuego
entre hamás y el ejército de israel en
una escalada de las tensiones recordemos
que muchos analistas situaron a como la
la masa tensa no la más violenta desde
2014 en que murieron 250 palestinos y 12
israelíes pues bueno esta imagen habla
por sí sola como todas y que vamos a ver
exacto la siguiente es de la frontera
entre eeuu y méxico está también la
hemos hablado muchas veces en esta serie
también el imperio
evidentemente raúl es que esta imagen
pues como ya he dicho otras veces me
deja francamente sin palabras de hecho
la propia casa blanca no la considero
horrible sin embargo suele suceder que
molestan las imágenes pero las políticas
no cambian raúl vemos la siguiente que
tiene hace referencia a lo sucedido aquí
en colombia durante el paro nacional o
en un tema que seguimos aquí muy de
cerca en este canal esto es aquí en la
plaza bolívar en bogotá vemos la
siguiente porque también tiene que ver
con protestas pero esta vez en mi alma
recordemos contra el golpe de estado de
principios de febrero de este mismo año
no una represión pues sangría en brutal
en este país asiático vamos a la
siguiente porque raúl también ha sido el
fin de la era merkel y aquí vemos a la
canciller alemana todavía en funciones
junto con armin la de siete en el
candidato del cdu que finalmente pues no
será el nuevo canciller de alemania
recordemos que ayer se anunció
definitivamente el nuevo pacto de
gobierno aquí pues protestas pro y anti
aborto en eeuu a ver si podemos acabar
con algunas imágenes
bueno free britney y ya terminamos con
la última bueno esto en el tigre esta
imagen es de de junio bueno kabul
raúl estas imágenes de edad de la
evacuación de este aeropuerto tras la
salida de eeuu y ya el poder alcanzado
por restar y si es por nosotros seguimos
aquí viendo esta imagen
derio en un meneo en un icono de la
cultura pop y si es por nosotros los que
vamos aquí viendo todas las fotos pero
ya nuestro productor nos regaña así que
rosa terminamos en esta revista presa
por el [__] y recuerde que si quiere
ver todas las fotos puede ingresar a la
revista 'time' para ver toda esta
selección de las 100 mejores fotos de
2021 gracias rosa nueva mañana vamos
ahora con nuestra primera italia
[Música]